this one is the easiest thing of all
time would you rather be stuck on a
desert Island deserted island deserted
island uh for the next three years or
have to live in rural Ohio for the rest
of your life I mean I'll do I'll do a
year on the [__] Island rural Ohio is
just like a landlock deserted one year
on the island I'll do it like there's no
way even if it was 3 years on a deserted
island uh you kidding me or 3 years in
Ohio I'd still think I'd do three years
in a deserted island yeah if it was 3
years on a deserted island and one year
I'll take the deserted island here's the
thing about deserted Islands though when
when we say deserted island people
always assume hey it's a tropical island
you know what if it's a deserted island
somewhere with shitty weather like in
the Arctic or in the Arctic or some [__]
like that died near one yeah I would
rather still live there though than
Ohio I can take the co it's just white
Ohio what can you get whiter than Ohio
no it's like like Ohio but you changed
the filter to
White not not white people that's what I
thought you were saying I thought you
were saying no I don't think you gets
wider than that all right this is a
three for uh one for each of us so for
me would you rather watch Arcane or join
the next chess boxing tournament uh
chess boxing tournament 100% what that's
no you've got to be that you you're
meing there's no way no I would you
would rather get beat up and train for a
year then watch a [__] 12 10 hour
show yeah there's no shot yeah cuz I get
shape and I'd get better at chest and
you'd have your you'd be you'd come back
like and I'd win some money if I you'd
come back and you'd be like oh my p
don't work
concussion yeah so I'd rather go to
frontal La Bon than arane uh for G would
you rather eat only Pizza cross for a
week for k or and uh wait what for have
to dip everything you eat to dip
everything to dip everything you eat for
the next week into ketchup Mir oh that's
good oh this this is actually very very
easy um yeah honestly I cannot stand
ketchup and Mayo I just more than pizza
crust more than pizza crust I could I I
can me and pizza crust can uh make peace
for a second uh if I don't have to dip
ketchup and Mayo I remember what us
talking about how our taste buds change
things like that I think as coming
around a pizza cross I think as I've
grown older I have come to hate ketchup
even more as I did as a kid I've every
time I seem to try it now it just seems
to get like the taste always gets more
and more sickening to me also it I think
the caveat here is it says you have to
dip everything you eat right and there's
probably a lot of things that are not
going to go well with ketchup anyway
like I unless you unless you selectively
choose foods that go well with I can
pretend look I can pretend to be like
you've been to parties with me I can
pretend to be a normal person my pizza
cross every now and again if it's like
if I have like the social obligation to
be like okay this is the first time I'm
meeting people let's just try to fit in
for a second but in no way were can I
ever turn off that part of my brain that
says just dip it in the ketchup Mayo if
it's KY Mayo maybe but ketchup I draw
the line of ketchup I just cannot stand
ketchup even spicy ketchup even spicy
ketchup like really like mild
difference yeah know and then for Connor
would you rather eat only oranges for a
week or have to sit through all of the
Fate L explanation videos for a week oh
this is a good one um for fate L
explanation like for a week what does
that mean does that mean like 24 hours a
day I'm sitting there 24 hours 7 days a
week you have to have explanation
however however like a marathon like
however yeah however long you would take
to get through all of the Fate La
explanation I guess which would probably
be a week straight if we're being honest
probably fate law really really you hate
oranges that much [__] hate them
they're awful why would I want like a
scrotum texture thing that tastes of
just water and scrotum texture how do
you find point me to the last time you
tasted a SC how do you find a new thing
to hate about oranges every single week
they suck dude they just suck I just
don't like I at least I get to watch
something I like watching random
explainer videos about [__] I don't care
about so this is right up my alley
especially my week anyway someone tell
me about why I should care about like I
don't know cigarette companies likew is
interesting anyway SK oh you Skip One
yeah all right go for G okay so Derek
Wills asks let's start off uh let's
start are fun would you rather it hurt
every time you pee or have it hurt every
time you poop so basically would you
rather have an STD or gar
basically poop wait does gor make your
shits hurt gonor Yeah well yeah I've
never had G know I don't know that I I
don't know if that's true either is it
gor or is it no hemorrhoids Hamid
hemorrhoids I like G as an STD Joe an st
right sorry would you so would you
rather have it
I'm glad I I fact checked it yeah my bad
that's my bad on
that wait wait what is
goria now I'm confused pull up
goria we're going to learn something
today shout out to everyone who watches
trash taste while you are eating this
this is for you guys what is garia okay
it's an STD it's it is an STD okay um I
just know that oh so it's like a it's
like a yri
uh infection yeah so it's almost like a
UTI I guess which almost I guess what it
caused by the garia bacterium it says
yeah fair enough okay so rephrase yeah
would you rather have an STD where it
hurts to pee or would you rather have
hemorrhoids I have not had either so
I've not had either but I I pee more
than I poop so actually can can I ask
what is hemorrhoids I know it's
hemorrhoids is well there's hemorrhoids
is when you basically have like a cut uh
in your like on your butthole yeah it's
inside though it can be inside or
outside really I thought it's inside no
I think there's two different kinds so
you can get
inside don't bring up Google Images yeah
yeah yeah Mudan do not put any of these
images on screen right now this
hemorrhoids this is just uh for us
hemorrhoids is the swelling and around
[Music]
Uranus that's a yeah so you can have it
internal or external about half of
people will have hemorrhoids by age 50
oh [__] [__] I mean maybe we have had
hemorrhoids we just don't know what I
don't know what hemorrhoids is I'm not
having no you would I'm pretty sure you
would have hemorrhoids why because it's
you can get why would you say like that
because because you if you spend too
long [__] sitting for long periods
of time especially on the toilet is a
main C if you spend ages pushing your
bows like tensing and [__] that's
how you get it I don't spend ages just
tensing though yes you do don't [__]
lie you on the toilet for like 10 hours
I let it I let it like [__] naturally
go man there's no there's no I don't
like I don't like sit on the toilet and
I'm like Goku Going [__] Super Saiyan
for 30 minutes straight Jesus Christ I'm
just relaxing you know he's letting
gravity do the work yeah yeah yeah you
let gravity do the
work we do a bet if you have hemorrhoids
by 50 450 you give me $100 you don't get
hemorrhoids I'll give you $100 wait what
do I get out of this what you mean so if
you don't get hemorrhoids you get $100
and you don't get hemorrhoids soon bonus
bonus points if I get hemorrhoids yeah
before age 50 I give you
$1,000 have you guys ever had a I don't
know if this is like TMI have you guys
ever had a UTI uh no I haven't I haven't
no I I don't know how I I somehow got
one but I don't know if this is the
normal way to get one there was this one
time where I just held a pee for like a
really really long time like a really
really [__] long time uh cuz I
couldn't find a toilet cuz I was in
England uh and then suddenly everything
just burned it's UTI is just awful
sounds like it I like I make sure to pee
don't hold in your pee just just I'm
saying this now this comes from
experience uh don't hold in your pee
because I didn't know it could cause a
UTI I just thought you you to deal with
this recently what's that you had to
deal with this recently oh yeah yeah
yeah cuz Aki had a a kidney infection
and uh it it's but for her it didn't
hurt to pee she just felt like [__] yeah
some sometimes yeah I think sometimes it
depends sometimes it does sometimes this
is why whenever I get that intense urge
to pee I'm like I just got to do it yeah
I I can't stop I kind of got like a mock
feeling of it when I ate that ghost
pepper on the live stream and then my
pee turn spicy that [__] that [__] hurt
I was like ah is this what it feels like
the worst thing about it is that having
it you constantly feel like you have to
pee yeah even though even even if you
don't right what's the is it just anti
anti biotics is that how you yeah
antibiotics I hate that so boring what
you mean so boring medieval treatment
give me some blood letting or something
you put the leeches on the my
dick your dick already feels like it's
having like a [__] with a leech on the
end of your
C suck it all out every time my dick
will get
sucked
I is this what felacio
is Medieval [__] be like
well you know you know when you you know
the the only time I've test the you know
my my urge to pee and I fight it is when
you're in bed and you're sleeping and
you wake up and you're it's maybe like
midnight you're about to fall asleep and
you can feel the pee coming yeah and
you're like it's not strong enough where
I need to pee but I know that there's a
chance I'll wake up in the middle of the
night or I'll wake up in the morning
feeling like it's also the worst when
it's like a cold winter night and it's
really cold outside the blanket you're
like is this cold worth it for me to get
out of the wall to go pee this will be
on the it'll be uploaded by then but I I
on Chris's uh Broad in Japan yeah Broad
in Japan is that what it is no joury
that's his channel name uh the first
thing he made me do I arrived in Sendai
he's like guys we're going camping and I
was like oh no in the it's like thec I
was like oh no oh no why why and um I
was like I I told him you remember we we
when we went camping I and you and did
you [__] up did you [__] up with the the
the sleeping bag did you get to yeah
yeah yeah I got the Amazon one we all
[__] up with the sleeping bags right
and I told him I was like you got to get
a winter sleeping bag I don't want to go
through that again I that genuinely
scared me yeah yeah Prett traing I I was
actually so scared CU we went we went
camping in Fuji recap we went camping in
Fuji it went to Minus 5 yeah and we had
Amazon basic sleeping bags which were
not
rated they were like summer sleep it
might as well be a cardboard bag and uh
I didn't have any clothes I didn't have
anything and I was like you [__]
you I swear to God I kept telling him
cuz I when I he he was like it's a
secret I can't tell you what we're doing
and then someone told me and I was like
we're going camping and I found out he's
really annoyed and I was like do you
have everything he's like we have an
expert we have an expert I was like I
don't believe you do you have have you
confirmed we have winter sleeping bags
cuz this [__] is no [__] joke it
snows in the mountains especially and
and we were on a [__] Island a tiny
Island about the size of our office in
the middle of an ocean man Chris really
makes you do the [__] stuff I telling
him this I was like I have the best
experience I you bastard I I have been
on this is my first one Joey has been on
like 19 of these and Joey only gets nice
cushy things they're all great why do I
have to be the one a [__] survival
situation so anyway we get there right
and he's like oh yeah we got to camp and
you know we' this ton of stuff on this
boat we so much stuff and I'm like okay
we have way too much stuff these guys
are prepared like crazy man this is
awesome and I'm setting at my tent I'm
setting up Chris's tanks of course he
doesn't want to set up his own
tankal
there was a good time lapse that that
Paul had it was really funny maybe laugh
Paul's like look at this it's like Paul
Chris on his phone watching and you just
see like me and Paul and naty building
the tents and Chris is just on his phone
watching it's very funny I I don't I
don't care I just find it really funny
um but um anyway so I I get the sleeping
rag out and I look at it and I'm like
Chris it's only rated to like two
degrees Yeah it's going to get minus 5
tonight again yeah that's this is this
is Nightmare return [__] sucks and I was
like I can't do this again I can't I
can't get me out of here like can I
leave like this is awful cuz I I knew
the [__] storm that was awaiting me I've
already done it luckily this time I
brought uh some really good uh under
thermal stuff brought nice thick socks
but dude it didn't do anything again it
was [__] awful well because you're
also sleeping on the cold ground as well
yeah and we only had cuz last time we
had like a mat yeah we had a mat last
time didn't have a mat this time we had
a very thin like uh reflective thing sh
so you're closer to the ground we on
that's why you lose most of your heat
yeah dude and this is why I was why I
bring up the story because I managed to
get warm but what I had to do to get
warm is is I had to cuz you know the
sleeping bag the back of the head is
larger right I had to do this did you do
this as well oh no sorry I I was just
like realizing before we talked about
this we're talking about peeing so I was
like are you going to say you peed
yourself W maybe warm myself up I was
like I was like where's the story going
how does this all so we I had these we
had these footwers but we only had two
each uh and so I put these foot warmers
on my feet and said it lasted three
hours I was like great I can get to
sleep and then I'll be fine yeah yeah
and I still so cold but my feet were
fine I had to get the back of the
sleeping bag I turned it over so it was
over my face yeah folded it over my head
made like a a cocoon and I had to keep
breathing into this sleeping bag so I
wouldn't lose the moisture heat so I
heat myself up to so cold again and I
got to sleep [__] finally uh
breathing the same carbon monoxide that
I was breathing out and then I woke up
at three I don't think you slept I think
you just knocked yourself
out I woke up at three with the most
strongest intense urge to pee in my life
yeah but I knew if I if I if I left this
sleeping bag it was game over like I
would never be able to get warm again
the entire night cuz it was a pee
coldness so I tried to sleep it off for
an hour I tried to sleep couldn't sleep
I had to pee so I go out I go pee I'm
like [__] freezing I get back in my
sleeping bag I just cannot get warm so I
I can't sleep cuz it's just too cold and
I'm just there shivering like [__] [__]
Chris [__] Chris the whole time I can
hear Chris ripping plastic like little
plastic you know like scrunching he's
ripping out like the kidol like the heat
yeah charcoal one of those ones yeah he
was opening these packs for like 30
minutes I go on his 10 in the morning he
had like 40 of them it was
insane uh it was the worst night I've
had in years uh [__] awful and that
was your first journey across Japan I'm
never going back ever again I'm never
going back ever again [__] this the
point being that that that P surge was
so intense that I I was considering
pissing myself but I knew that it would
have made me colder ultimately so you
would rather have it hurt every time you
poop uh
P after all that point being uh yeah oh
we also they told us on the island if
you wanted to take a [__] you to climb
up the hill take a [__] in the ground uh
dig a hole first and then Pat it in I
was like I'm not doing that I'm going to
[__] myself that's the Aussie way
[__] doing that but that was just a
fun little story yeah I mean [__] Chris
by the way when he comes on the show I'm
maybe you should pee yourself next time
that's that will keep you warm like good
like half an hour right yeah but then
you freeze yeah that's true and also
you'd be trapping yourself in the PE STI
sleeping cover monoxide poisoning and
now like wet pants as well ended up
getting up waking up at like 6 being
like [__] this I'm was going to make a
fire front of smell like an animal D so
I just sat in front of a fire for 4
hours until the boat came to pick us up
all right but moving on to the next
would you rather uhhuh uh you want
something dark as [__] would you rather
watch oh wow you want to read out of
would you rather watch all your friends
and family die are be forced to kill 100
strangers I'll kill the strangers I kill
the strangers oh are we doing like
they're in PCS they'll respa this is
literally just the blood of Attack on
Titan this is this like the train
problem except one side is your friends
and family and the other side are a
bunch of people that you don't know and
you're like okay well yeah